so our next topic is uh Ridge regression
and the lasso uh you'll be happy to know
that uh the python professional is
back yes well thank you Trevor okay um
so we we just saw a forward stepwise
selection which gives us a way to choose
important variables in the model and um
we'll see uh these other two methods
Ridge regression the last Ridge
regression isn't really a selection
method but the lasso is something
something like forward forward stepwise
that it does model selection as well as
as
estimation okay so we're going to use um
the uh elastic net method uh from siteid
learn and we use that uh to be for
Simplicity in that it fits both the
ridge regression and the lasso uh in
fact there's it sort of interpolates
between them that's one of the things we
we saw in the in the chapter and I'll
just make a note here that when you run
this code right now there are a lot of
warnings for Ridge regression in
particular and that has something to to
do with a um you know arguably a a bug
uh in any case the solution is actually
fine so we can ignore those warnings uh
for now in any case but just just a
heads up
okay um so what we're going to do is
we're going to use the same data uh now
in the chapter when we talked about rid
regression and lasso we noted that it's
it's common to scale the data before you
use rid regression or lasso just because
so you're penalizing each variable in a
comparable fashion so we're going to uh
scale the data first we could have used
the the standard scaler method but we
just at this point hand scale it um and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to get a ridge uh solution path so
that's using this psychic learn elastic
net. path method and for that um we give
it this array of values of Lambda the
argument Lambda is called Alpha in the
in the elastic net package but that's
what Lambda is in the book and this L1
ratio here this is the that parameter
that uh interpolates between the ridge
regression estimator and the lasso
estimator so at zero this is the ridge
regression estimator and at one it's the
lasso estimator so we'll see later when
we do the lasso all we have to change is
this from zero to
one okay and uh so we we asked for this
path and it gives us uh a 19 by 100
Matrix there are 19 features and we have
100 values of Lambda so each row of this
is going to be a a a path for a single
coordinate and we'll plot those in just
a
second
so we can look at the um the data uh and
here what I've done psyched learn
doesn't actually have variable names but
I've added some variable names to the
features and an index of Lambda values
so uh to be a little you know more more
informative but you can see now um I've
transposed that array so now each column
is a solution path as a function of
Lambda down
here okay let's get to the here's a
plot
um and so you can that's a pretty blood
yes they're they're nice smooth curves
the ridge regression estimated the
Legend's a little bit big we might want
to opt you know put that in a different
place if we were producing but it's in
it's in a good place at least it's not
sitting over the coefficient path so
Jonathan each curve is what each curve
corresponds to one of the features so I
think this blue one here is at bat and
you know unfortunately the color blue
repeated a little bit but I I'm going to
say that this is the coefficient for at
bat uh
and when lamb this is minus log Lambda
down here so this corresponds to a very
large value of Lambda and that's a lot
of penalization and we can see that all
the coefficients under here are right
around zero and then as Lambda gets
smaller and smaller that is minus log
Lambda grows we get towards the
ordinarily Square solution so these
values here should correspond pretty
closely to if we just fit ol lovely
PL
okay so you can uh extract you know
individual coefficients if you like um
by uh well just by looking at the
solution path we we we constructed and
what we're going to see here is that for
different values of Lambda so remember
Lambda is decreasing as we increase the
index so we'll compare Lambda the 40th
entry Lambda 39 to the 50th Lambda 59
and what we should see is that at 59 we
sort of relax the penalty so it should
be a bit bigger so we're just going to
you know compute the you know we can
inspect the coefficients but we'll just
compute the Norms at the two different
values so at at the 40th Lambda the
coefficient Vector is length
24 and at the 60th Lambda the
coefficient Vector has length 160 and
you can see that you know these are just
two different places on this axis as we
go down the path the vector gets longer
so that's the the sum of squares of the
coefficients yes at those two different
values of Lambda yes uh well sorry it's
the square root it's the norm it's sare
just looking at that yeah you know it is
related I just wanted to answer it
correctly so I look check the code so
the code is
helpful okay um so we had we had
computed the above with using the path
method but if you want just a single
value you can use the elastic net
estimator instead and give it a specific
value of alpha rather than a path of
Alphas um so earlier I said we could
have used the scaler to uh to
standardize our um our data we had hand
SC hand standardized Data before we're
going to instead combine these methods
now in this thing called a pipeline so
this is a a sid learn object that allows
you to combine different steps of a
procedure um and it might seem a little
bit like Overkill but um what's nice
about the pipeline as we'll see later uh
you can each of these estimators have
different tuning parameters and you
could like wiggle them a little bit and
then automatically cross validate over
different grids of the parameters so I
see so is the point here Jonathan that
each time we if we use cross validation
in each fold we want to standardize the
training data in the fold yeah that's
what using this pipeline that will do
that and that will do it for you that's
very handy yeah whereas if you call if
we just if we used our X scale here that
we had done before it would have done a
global standardization not within each
fold okay so for something like
standardization it may not matter too
much but for other Transformations you
might want to repeat it on each fold so
this pipeline method allows you to do
that I can see it's very useful yes and
so the pipeline method is just another
pyit learn estimator so we can cross
validate it just like any other psychic
learn estimator um and it will give us
an estimate of whatever metric we use we
saw earlier you could we could compute
negative CP with this or whatever a
custom metric is can't wait to see the
result yes and one as we'll see one of
the other nice things that you can
search over variations in the parameters
here right Ridge has a parameter we saw
up here where oh it's right here R has a
par Alpha if we give a the same set of
Alphas that we give to the path argument
it will search over those same paths to
find the optimal
CV okay so let's use
um the uh SIDS learns cross validation
or in this case we're going to do a test
train split
uh it's using the same cross validation
function but it's actually going to
compute a use the validation method to
estimate um error and I we know that
it's using the validation method because
instead of using kfold we're using this
Shuffle split and this
corresponds test size is 50% that
corresponds to split test and training
equally and uh setting the random State
fixes the split uh for so that when we
rerun this code we'll get the same
answer um so this gives us you know
using uh oh this is just using the r oh
I guess I should have maybe we should
have used pipe here but so this is the
the cross validation error of the ridge
estimator and that's one of the um the
parts of the
pipeline okay and we can you know change
the parameters of the estimator rerun
cross validation um and it will use the
same split as it did previously because
we had fixed the state and at this point
we've used a very large value of Lambda
to get something like the null model so
the null cross validation error or
null uh test error with a test Trin
split is about uh 230,000 compared to
about 134,000 for the ridge estimator so
quite an
improvement and if we wanted to use uh
um cross Val validation a kfold of
course all we would have to do is change
this argument here to be some uh a kfold
argument instead of the the the test
training split so
now we'll do the same thing but we'll um
we're going to use the pipe estimator
which actually scales and standardizes
um each time and we're going to this is
an example here that where we'll see how
to search over a grid of parameters so
this uh this function grid search CV it
takes some form of cross validation in
this case this is this test train split
we saw above um and it takes of course
we have to describe the variation in the
parameter so that's this argument param
grid and so we've told the way the
format of this is is well there was an
estimator called Ridge and it has an
alpha parameter so this Ridge double
underscore Alpha this is tells SK learn
to vary Alpha along all these values
Lambda does and those are the same 100
values we saw
before
okay and as I said if we want to use
kfold cross validation instead of the
test train split we would just give this
argument the kfold argument so now when
we this again is an estimator s learn
estimator so we again fit it on our X
and Y and then at the end it has these
uh these new attributes the best params
and the best
estimator
and our grid of parameters here only had
a single entry so the best pams you know
has an entry for Ridge Alpha um and this
best estimator is well this pipeline
where the ridge Alpha is set to the best
Alpha so um that's what this
returns
okay let's see and of course we could
have um there's maybe not for our for
our pipeline here there's not that many
other interesting parameters in the
scaler but there could have been
something maybe in the we could have
tuned the L1 ratio um to go from Ridge
regression to lasso but we haven't even
seen lasso yet so we'll see that coming
up
okay so besides finding the best
estimator it also um computes the the
the score within each fold like we did
by hand before right so earlier we saw
for forward stepwise we had uh 20 models
and five different folds so we had 20
by5 Matrix of mean squared error uh for
the for this data here we'll have about
aund there'll be 100 by5 Matrix um and
it actually uh computes the mean test
score for us and the standard deviation
of the test score all by itself so it's
done what we did by hand automatically
very good and so we can make a plot
similar to what we saw in forward
stepwise but the axis here is different
this is the regularization parameter in
forward stepwise this was the uh the the
the complexity here was going from the N
model with just an intercept to all 20
features here it goes from the N model
to well the or or Os model but along
this Ridge path and we'll see for the
last similar path shortly similar a
little bit to forward stepwise in that
it doesn't increase at the the end it
just sort of gets down and stays flat
that's right so I mean we talk about in
the book that you know eventually you'd
expect these curves to sort of turn up
but for the data sets we've happened to
use we haven't seen the overfitting in
very drastic overfitting there's a
slight turn up but it's not abrupt um
then again it's only 20 features so it's
not that complicated a
model when picking uh you know
optimizing parameters in a CV grid you
have to pick your metric so here I we
included this metric we wanted to use
mean squar error and of course to
maximize it it's negative mean squ error
so that's what that string indicates if
we hadn't done that it would be R squ so
that's what the last plot here shows so
without saying anything the meth the
estimator uses r squ as a metric and
this is similarly there'll be 100 by5
Matrix of R squares we will average
those and um and get the center the
errors that's what this plot is
producing okay and of course it has the
same form because r s is very closely
related okay so lastly I want to talk
about uh something for um for Ridge both
Ridge regression and the lasso is that
there are very fast methods to do cross
validation so we above we searched over
Lambda using the grid the the pipeline
and the grid search CV method they're
custombuilt ones for for elastic net
that's this elastic net CV function
okay so what this is essentially going
to do is the same thing we just did but
it's it's it's very specially built for
the elastic net uh that is the rid
estimator and upcoming elasto estimator
because uh it's a commonly used
method so if we plot the msse out of
that this plot is unsurprisingly very
similar to what we saw before uh this
was just to show there's a specialized
method okay um
so I think uh well the I'm going to skip
this in the interest of time so what
this section of code what it does is it
recognizes that in tuning a parameter
like by cross
validation we might we are still still
somewhat left in the without without an
honest estimate of error so what this
split what we've done here is split into
training and test run cross validation
on the training data and then evaluate
the final estimator on the test test
data and so that's why there's a split
here into training and test a kfold
cross validation and well that's what
the code will will compute
here so it's
132,000 it's not that different from the
actual cross validated one we saw
before okay so our final uh method in
this uh lab is the the lasso and as as
we mentioned earlier in the lab this is
a a method that does selection like
forward stepwise as well as regularized
estimation like Ridge regression um and
so as we mentioned earlier the
difference between bridge and lasso in
terms of the code at least this version
of the code we're using is this L1 ratio
at zero this is the ridge estimator at
one it's the lasso
estimator so we're going to you know fit
a path of alasso path of solutions using
the same function elastic net CV we saw
above um
though it will give us the lasso fit
this time instead of the ridge fit
because of this difference in the
parameters okay so as we did for the
ridge regression we can make a data
frame and you can inspect that if you
like of the the solution paths to the um
blasso and we can also make a plot uh
like we did for the ridge estimators so
this plot is going to be interpreted
very similarly to the ridge regression
estimator though it looks a little bit
different um let's see Trevor what's the
biggest thing you notice about this plot
the biggest thing I noticed is it's it's
not as smooth as the as the earlier one
and and some coefficients are zero for a
large portion of the path and then they
jump away from zero of course of course
Trevor knew the answer to that question
before but okay so yes the lasso um if
you know for at my age you can't rely on
that uh so for for some large values of
Lambda remember this is minus log Lambda
so these are large values of Lambda so a
lot of the coefficients are zero and in
fact hidden under this Legend which is
um a little unfortunate they're all zero
at the beginning and then some
coefficients come in one by one and
sometimes they actually go out I'm not
sure yes in this we can see maybe a
little coefficient come off and then go
back to zero and then come off again so
these paths are well as we change Lambda
the lasso solution changes and what's
notable about the lasso as we talked
about in the lecture is of course that
it can do selection it can set some
coefficients exactly to Z so if we
select a value of Lambda around here
then uh this will correspond to a you
know we'll have a a solution with maybe
this looks like seven or eight non-zero
coefficients out of a total 20 um so
this this estimate this is sort of in
between the Ridge and forward stepwise
and it's a you know quite a popular
estimator okay we can uh look at our our
um test error uh so using the optimal
test test error for Ridge I guess our
going back was 115,000 for lasso it's
about
115,000 very similar very similar yes
and let's just look at one big
difference before I go back to the plot
one big difference is that when we
looked at the um the optimal choice of
Lambda the coefficient Vector for the
lasso actually does have some zeros so
it's actually selected I think five or
six coefficients out of the 19 to be
zero whereas The Ridge of course all
them are non-zero some of them might be
small but they're
nonzero and as in the ridge regression
example we can also make this plot of
cross validated mean squared error to
choose and I've indicated here the uh
the Lambda selected as the best um using
uh this the 54k cross
validation okay so that wraps up the lab
for chapter 6 for what we'll talk about
today there is an additional section on
principal components aggression and
partial Le squares regression that uh we
encourage you to do
offline